[Music]
if you're a fan of HGTV like me this
might look familiar to you pop corn
ceilings these eyesores are staples in
many old homes and therefore star in
many home renovation shows so why do
these ceilings exist where do they come
from why are these things seemingly
everywhere when everyone finds them just
ugly and finally how do we get rid of
them to start off popcorn ceilings
otherwise known as acoustic ceilings
were born out of laziness that's right
they were actually considered a
budget-friendly shortcut because of this
it became widely adopted which is why
you could find them in so many old homes
today they were especially popular from
the 1930s all the way through the 1990s
popcorn ceiling texture is a spray this
applied to your ceiling it was used to
cover up a lot of flaws in the ceiling
it was time effective cost efficient and
as you may have heard it called before
an acoustic ceiling it also served the
purpose to absorb sound and reduce noise
nowadays the style is simply outdated
it's not that the style was ever
appealing in the first place new
homeowners and renovators are putting
popcorn ceilings at the top of their
list of what needs to go first really
what it's about is hiding any
imperfections that might be missing
instead of doing a perfectly smooth
drywall so inherently these popcorn
ceilings are supposed to hide
imperfections but really after time they
collect dust
the craters create shadows and it really
ends up being a distraction and a little
bit of an eyesore
besides homeowners wanting something a
little less cottage cheesy there's
another big issue facing popcorn
ceilings asbestos
according to Princeton University's
Environmental Health and Safety website
asbestos is a generic term used to
describe any of six naturally occurring
fibrous materials because of its
positive qualities such as its strength
and heat resistance it was widely used
in building construction beginning in
the late 1800s it was commonly used for
things like fire proofing material for
steel beams and columns added to
concrete asphalt floor tiles pipes and
as a component in mixtures for sprayed
on ceilings and walls hmm but if it's
good for pretty much everything what's
the issue
well problems arise when these things
are damaged crumbled or in this case
when someone tries to remove it the
fibers in the asbestos mineral can be
harmful when inhaled and lead to serious
health risks throughout the 1970s the
Environmental Protection Agency began
heavily regulating asbestos in different
use cases and materials eventually that
led to a ban on asbestos containing
spray applied servicing materials aka
sprayed on popcorn ceilings by the early
1980s most products containing asbestos
had been removed from the market in the
United States so should you be moving
out of your house in a panic if you're
living in a place with popcorn ceilings
no one left intact and undisturbed these
materials do not pose a health risk to
people living in it
despite the outdated style and wealth
asbestos popcorn ceilings still taught
many homes throughout the u.s.
but if you're looking into buying a new
property you're going to want that
sucker gone I can't tell you in
particular how many homes across the
country or the globe have hot bread
feelings I can tell you that more than
17,000 of our listings on realtor.com
tout no popcorn ceilings or the popcorn
ceilings have been removed so it's
definitely a point that home sellers are
trying to make it's a very clear message
to buyers
hey we've taken care of it but what if
you find a beautiful home and the
buzzkill is the popcorn ceiling well
Rachel knows something about that too so
if you fall in love with a house that
has popcorn ceilings don't despair you
can get rid of them you can do it
yourself and save a little bit of cash
but it is a pretty intensive DIY project
so more than likely you're gonna want to
call it professional and usually the
average cost for a popcorn ceiling
removal is about one to two dollars per
square foot and that doesn't sound like
much but it can add up quickly so do the
math and figure out what works for you
but know that you may end up recouping
those costs when you sell down the road
the textured ceilings aren't just
unsightly to look at their actual upkeep
and maintenance is also pretty difficult
if you have a popcorn ceiling and you
try to patch and repair if you have some
type of leak or some other damage and
it's really tough to do and try to make
it match nowadays home renovators are
offering professional and safe services
specifically to get rid of popcorn
ceilings and many companies are creating
DIY tools for removing them like Poppy's
for example
DIY projects are good for saving some
cash but if you're not a professional do
some research on how to protect yourself
and definitely test for asbestos before
getting your hands dirty